all right thanks everybody so we have
the schedule uh we have a couple of the
schedule
uh so
if you look at the schedule the first
hour uh
more or less we're going to be spending
it doing a little bit level setting
uh giving a little bit of background
uh what are the goals and expectations
you know what are we going to be doing
and you know if we have some if we
finish a little early we'll start
straight into the material right so the
idea that uh you know so for during this
first hour
uh
you know we're going to talk about the
resources what is there you know
essentially
you know machine learning i think
everybody has
even a little bit of experience some
people have more experience so people
have a lot of experience so everybody
has either read a paper read a you know
an article or
taken a course or worked on it or play
with some software solve the problem so
more or less at this point
there's a lot of people that most people
have have an exposure to machine
learning right so the goal in this uh is
uh this class is to go a little bit
deeper right to
essentially to become a little bit more
fluent essentially in the in the way of
solving problems using machine learning
so we'll elaborate a little bit more
about that i'll also talk about the some
of the things we're going to be doing in
the in these three days including the
lab challenge
right so uh you probably all hopefully
downloaded or got the tar file
with the material right the material
there essentially
has some code that we're going to be
looking at
there's some libraries or some programs
that we're going to be running and doing
some exercises on them
has a this pdf and other pdf that are
essentially the syllabus the handout
and also has the data sets that's most
important right because in the data sets
it's what we're going to be playing with
and the data sets we're going to be
working the labs we're going to be doing
the labs and the data sets is going to
be part of the we're going to use them
to do our our challenge that is you know
again i'll talk a little bit more about
that
uh what the challenge is about
all right and then uh during again this
hour i also talk about the
10 concepts that you probably either
learned in college
and you forgot about them or you
probably
didn't really learn it because you know
nobody talked about it but i think that
are more or less the 10 things that you
know you should perhaps should learn and
then you can we can uh you know again
level set this uh this class right it's
very very simple stuff
okay so as i said um so the the goal is
to become a little bit more fluent
in the
art or in the the task of solving
problems using machine learning so we
are engineers we are software engineers
or engineers of some sort our goal is to
solve problems
right maybe at scale maybe with higher
precision maybe at a certain speed maybe
better than our competitors maybe with
certain particular data so we all have a
particular problem right we place iq has
a very specific very interesting problem
very particular data set and we as
engineers have to solve problems so here
our goal is to become better problem
solvers using the tool of machine
learning right now for some people what
that means is reviewing a little bit
more in the theory right i think that if
you look at the theory right if you look
at the formulas what are the assumptions
of the algorithms you become a better
problem solver with those algorithms if
you know what the constraints the
limitations are
for some other people you they need
probably more you know hands-on
exercises right you know just to to see
how it feels to actually run the program
and see the output and get an intuition
right for some other people it's a
mixture of both some other people would
like to hear more details about advanced
techniques some other fundamentals so
hopefully there's going to be a little
bit of everything that here compressing
into these three days right but again
ultimately the common goal whether
you're very ex advanced or intermediate
or just beginning is to become a better
problem solving using machine learning
all right uh yes one before i continue
um
so in terms of copyrights the there you
guys have a syllabus a handout just the
text there is comes from several of the
textbooks right so i don't claim that to
be my original invention or i didn't
discover anything there so some of them
is really just sentences that were
copied from from textbooks i'll talk
about which textbooks which i recommend
that you get copy of them right so again
just uh
just mention i want to mention that
okay so um
so specifically right so how are we
gonna how are we going to become better
problem solvers right so as i said some
of us need a little bit more background
and theoretical uh some of us just need
a little bit more
demystification demystify right a little
bit the concept of machine learning or
try to see you know that using a
particular technique for a particular
approach just entails you know
understanding what's behind it and
running it and then what are the the
boundaries or limits of that of that
approach right
review the main techniques and
approaches right um that are not uh uh
and then
also
we we uh
goal of this uh class is to take a look
at some real world
cases right so i have in some use case
data
that are actually so one of the data
sets is actually a very very tiny
problem set that came from from place iq
right uh we can talk about other
problems that you know i've uh
encountered in the past some of you as i
said probably in your work have
particular problems and maybe we can
discuss them right i don't know if any
of you brought your data set to work on
it but that's that's fine uh we have
plenty of
of problems to review here
right um and then as i said hands-on
exploration through lab components
and you know at the end
hopefully all these will make you again
a better problem solver using machine
learning
okay so the
there are three data sets that are in
the tar file
and the first one i'll call it a shadow
dataset it's uh
as much as i could it's obfuscated but
it's actually real data from place eq
from a problem that we're trying to
solve it's very small it's very simple
but it gives you an idea of what the the
problems are actually sometimes the
problem comes from having a lot of data
and sometimes the problem comes from not
having enough data right so this is a
tiny problem and it's going to give you
a little bit more intuition of you know
overfitting what can you do when you
have you know a very very small amount
of data and still
certain techniques are very nice to be
run right uh and
but perhaps the assumptions of the of
the technique do not fit the data well
and how can you find that out quickly
and and what can you do about it so so
that data set is hopefully gonna um help
us uh take a look at that the second
data set is based on e-harmony right
that's available on the web and i think
that's a little bit harder because they
they actually this is a larger data set
the problem is a harmonies is matching
right whether it's a predicting is is
two two uh people are gonna individuals
are gonna be a good match or not but
this is a larger data set is obfuscated
they are not telling you what the
variables are and and the way the
problem is formulated is a little bit
more challenging so that's i give it a a
little bit harder level we will we will
be using it for our lab
and finally the hardest one is a data
set that comes from the census right
it's essentially a big table of uh
income
being predicted on other variables i
think this is the closest to real world
because it has many variables that have
mean
many possible values
uh you know you have to clean it
normalize it dimensionality reduction
all the munching and all that stuff and
at the end of the day you end up with a
very very large table and you have to do
you know the prediction you know what
are your assumptions in terms of the the
modeling approach so you know that's
probably the hardest right so um
when we do the the lab you can you you
can uh i will give you guidelines to
what to
uh
look at or work on each of these uh any
each of these data sets and then you can
choose any problem that you can you can
pick any of the three data sets and you
know again follow that approach right
and uh we will have some sort of uh
evaluation or competition at the end
i'll again tell a little bit more about
that later now in terms of books
um
you know there's a lot of books uh the
one of the big favorite books uh that
you know gets mentioned over and over
again is the bishop book and the uh tom
mitchell's book on machine learning
personally i like the the machine
learning book by murphy right that's my
favorite
um
and a lot of the content of the book of
the course is based on that in that book
if you can again i recommend you get a
copy the second one is also a very very
good book and is freely available in the
pdf on on the web right so uh you know
that should definitely download it and
the third one you know touches the topic
of kernels into more uh you know
emphasize focuses in that topic so you
know it's a good resource especially if
you think that you you're gonna continue
working on on kernels
okay um
okay now as i said
no most everybody has had some
experience using uh doing some sort of
being exposed to machine learning and
there are a lot of online courses
um
i look at some of them the one i found
uh
the most interesting is andrew nix from
stanford and uh his electric lecture
notes are very very good so you know
again i encourage that you you know go
if you're interested in going deeper in
a particular topic you can actually uh
you know check out the notes or the
class
now for this particular uh
um
course we're going to be looking into
two papers again that are available on
the web uh they are in part they're part
of the tar file
when we talk about em
estimation uh we will be looking at that
and when we and we'll talk about
logistic regression uh not because it's
a great explanation of logistic
regression but actually
everybody is a very popular paper
to understand and analyze
the results of logistic regression right
particularly like you know is this model
better than this other model right uh is
is this
good enough right this this model that i
just created was with logistic
regression is logistic regression a good
approach to solving this problem so that
paper actually follows a very uh deep
way of understanding logic regression so
those are part of the resources right of
the of the class
okay now um
so during the the class we're going to
have some hands-on
activities
and essentially this is what i think we
could uh the uh what you know we one way
or another we're gonna be using right um
so some of the code uh that this example
for for especially for the data first
data set the the place iq data set i
have some python code again it's not the
best code in the world but it's a clear
implementation of an algorithm
that you can uh you can again we have
the paper we have the code we have the
the the data and we're going to be
running experiments are you going to be
trying to improve it you can see very
easily how you know uh the the
the the algorithm is implemented and uh
you know we will be playing with that
for that we only need python however you
know as you get more advanced in uh
machine learning using python you you
would like to look at things at packages
like numpy scipy and scikit-learn right
those are very uh
common uh we'll probably be using uh r
um octave for the gaussian mixture
estimation
and as i said there's some code that uh
for logistic regression it's actually
yeah the the python code and some coding
for octave or matlab uh for uh em
right so
okay
now as uh as i said we're gonna have uh
during the course of three days
an ongoing exercise so
today we'll spend later on half hour
going into you know looking at the data
but the idea is that each of you
uh think a little bit and take a look at
the data set
and pick one
actually you can pick any of those three
or pick a fourth one that is your own
data set right
now um
as i said each of these data sets are
you know small medium and large easy
medium and hard and so what we're going
to have is some sort of a show and tell
at the end very quick i i realize that
we are uh you know
we cannot do a detailed show and tell
but it's going to be like a expression
until of two minutes each person
and you're gonna tell what you did with
that data set in these three days right
you don't probably you're gonna have
we're gonna have time here to work on it
so probably just spending a couple of
hours here in classroom working you know
interacting with me and the rest of the
class should be enough to do something
for your show and tell but if you want
to you know go home and work on it a
little bit further that's fine now the
there are three categories for for our
uh you know show and tell
again for um i'll talk about a little
bit more later but the for the first
category is the the person that advances
the most the accuracy of the of the
classifier i'll give you a benchmark the
code that is currently in python has a
certain accuracy if you the the person
that advances mass on
most
on the category
a on the first data set you know it's a
is going to be the winner of that
category for the second data set is the
e-harmony you guys have to crack the
code right you even though you don't
understand or we don't understand
because they're obfuscated the variables
the person that
essentially gets the best approach
whether it's a kernel or a feature
generation or some sort of uh modeling
that creates some sort of uh
direction towards increasing reducing
the the error rate in classification or
matching or best predictor matching wins
so that's that's going to be the the
hacker category because you guys are you
know in reverse engineering the or
cracking the harmony set and the third
one is the the census data set right the
person that gets any insight there
whether it is predictive or a pie chart
or you know this variable is correlated
with that variable or you know
you know a regression that makes sense
for the third data set and because it
involves the most cleaning and munching
and you know big picture kind of thing
that's going to be the data science
category so we have three categories and
you can pick any one you want you can
work on it for again the time here in
the classroom you can work at it at home
and at the end we're going to have a
show and tell and you know have
essentially they will vote for the best
uh
performance in each of the three
categories all right
okay so um
okay so let's uh let me show you this um
so
i've heard
recently some person talking about you
know the the cycle of how do you
solve the problem what are the steps of
solving a problem with machine learning
right and i think that's uh
very tricky because some problems are so
complicated that they don't really fit
this mold and some other problems you
know are uh too
particular to peculiar again to fit this
small too but i think this is a general
good uh you know
description of what the steps are when
you are solving a problem using machine
learning right so essentially the first
is you know you get your data you you
you take a look at the sniff of the data
you plot it you do scat scatter to take
a look at the
the variables
you probably start getting suspicious
that not all the variables are
independent so perhaps you start
thinking in terms of you know
how are you going to remove the
variables that are redundant
maybe you realize that your data is
sparse that maybe the values are missing
that maybe your data is skewed right
some uh some variables or some
categories are getting a lot of accounts
and or or
and so on so so the first is you get
your data and you analyze the data
then the second step typically you think
well you know i'm going to do a back of
the envelope analysis so i'm going to do
a classification i'm going to do a
prediction perhaps these techniques
works perhaps i'm going to use linear
regression or neural networks or
support vector machines or things of
that sort but at that point you start
getting ideas of why
certain algorithms are going to work or
are not going to work if you have too
many variables perhaps you know if you
have a naive approach that requires a
factorization of a matrix or things like
that you probably are going to think
well if g if i don't use a sparse
representation of my metrics there's no
way that this thing is going to fit in
memory right you start thinking well if
i don't uh you know sample it there's no
way that you know in my runtime it's
going to run fast enough on my mac so
probably i would need to run it in a
bigger machine so that's the second step
you start thinking well maybe i should
uh maybe it's not going to fit in r
right i should not use r um
so the third is actually um a lot of uh
what essentially
we spend the data science spent uh time
doing which is essentially is now
getting your data and starting putting
it in shape to to look like a machine
learning uh
uh ready right so you were munging
cleaning joining generating feature
imputing values removing outliers
essentially just cleaning up cleaning it
up and you know getting it ready
uh
after that a good idea is to start
thinking should i do a dimensionality
reduction right if i have 40 million
products or
100 million
you know features right or words right
maybe i don't want to use all of them
maybe i just want to focus on the top
100 maybe we want to do a projection
maybe i want to do some sort of a
transformation maybe just want to get
them the top most frequent or the most
discriminant so you do a dimensionality
reduction
then you you
once you have your data you have a more
or less reduce the dimensionality uh you
start thinking more seriously about the
algorithm right maybe does it sends it
makes sense to use just a linear
classifier
right perhaps you know sometimes that's
a good idea as long as perhaps you know
you do introduce some sort of
regularization and so on and so forth
once you have everything in place then
you essentially start learning the model
you learn the model you prune the
variables you are assessing the
performance is the system learning is
the likelihood increasing is the error
rate in my training data at least
reducing
and then
once you are comfortable that that's the
right direction you do some sort of
optimization some cross validation you
benchmark at the end hopefully you'll
have time to do error analysis and then
the the thing moves to production right
you might have a classifier a prediction
a matching that is doing that is running
on real time on a lot of data and you
just train your models in all these
steps
now uh so some thoughts uh as a that are
you know practical most of us are
working on projects that follow agile
right the methodology and have scrums i
have three week cycles you know
personally uh sometimes my managers are
thinking oh gee maybe we can do all this
in three weeks right so uh
that's uh
you know
i haven't seen it happening but uh but
what i what in my experience essentially
uh you know you probably do
kind of like a first pass iteration to
get you know some sort of a sense if the
algorithm is in is working
and then you know during a second and
third uh you know cycle you get to
improve the model and then you you worry
about the productization right so again
it's something that you it takes time
and then you know it becomes your job
right you probably start constantly
thinking about how to better clean these
features how to get better features how
to get more data how you know how to
create the pipelines that is constantly
going to be feeding you that data and
munching that data and things of that
sort so again some cycles some thoughts
about you know
this cycle in real life
okay so show of hands take a quick look
and just
if you were if i were to interview you
today right if you came to place i q an
interview and i asked you can you define
these diseases and this and this
so